Hey everyone! And welcome to our final installment. We are going to have a brief overview of antitrust laws and questionable business practices. Let's take a further look.
Antitrust laws go back to 1890 with the passage of the Sherman Antitrust Act. This was born out of the merger waves in the 1870s and 1880s. Congress needed a way to ensure that competition was not being stifled, so they turned to the Constitution and created this Act.
The first two sections set the tone and basically forbid monopolization.
There was a later amendment to instill the punishment if a party was found to have broken the law.
It's first test came against the E.C. Knight Company in 1895. It was an utter failure, even with that company controlling almost 98% of all sugar refining in the US. Over the next several years, the Act was, ironically, better at targeting unions than firms.
It would not be until 1904 that the first success took place by busting the Northern Securities Company—a railroad holding company—up. This was followed by another success against Standard Oil in 1911.
The Clayton Act was passed in 1914 and its purpose was to strengthen the Sherman Act.
Among its many caveats, it makes it illegal for sellers to price discriminate to buyers when it lessens competition or create a monopoly. And it allows for triple damages to individuals if the person was damaged by an illegal arrangement. This was done so the Justice Department could encourage more private lawsuits.
Several other acts were passed including the Federal Trade Commission Act of 1914.
The Robinson Patman Act of 1936 – which further strengthened price discrimination laws.The Wheeler-Lea Act of 1938 – which targeted false advertising.And the Celler-Kefauver Antimerger Act of 1950, which made it illegal to acquire the stock and assets of a competing corporation if it substantially lessened competition and tended towards a monopoly.
These acts have been used by the FTC and the Justice Department to ensure that competition remains in place.
Lastly, let's focus on some questionable business practices.The first is resale price maintenance.
Here a firm sells its products to retailers and, by contract, has those retailers sell the same products with a markup.
Does this lessen competition?
Not necessarily. In fact, it may help competition since consumers aren't getting information from one store and purchasing the good from another. And the firm has no desire for its retailers to form a cartel since cartels sell below an optimal quantity.
The next is predatory pricing.
This is the process of selling a good at or below cost. A firm will do this to drive competition out of the market.
The problem here is that the firm has to incur an economic loss for a sustainable period of time. Just how long can a firm keep this up?
That's difficult to say without knowing what the books look like. Besides, is this really a good business practice? "It's just
good business."
Our last is tying.
There are two types of tying. The first is a requirement tie-in sale.
Here the customer is required to buy a second or third product or more when they purchase the first product from the firm. A typical example of this is office equipment.
When a copier is purchased the business also has to purchase the servicing of that copier from the copier firm.
The second is bundling or package tie-in sales. These are the combination of two or more goods together and selling them for one price. Phones and operating systems. Cable and internet. Even your fast food meals. Alright everyone! That's it! I hope you have enjoyed them all.